all right and we are live with the
Morning Edition flashpoint
ybox it's what's going on in well you
know just the usual stuff here this week
at Bungie a little something else to get
sidetracked with you know good things in
the world try to focus on the good
that's so we tried to do we don't deal
with all the other stuff I'll take a
look the night time TV personalities mid
take care of the bed unfun stuff in the
world in the war trailer drop ran the
world just broke I just want to go buy
my tickets I'm like any CA I'd like
Thursday and then Friday just like all
the time I just parked my butt in the
theater for like 12 hours they're like
we have other people I'm like about the
seat all day I was like it's 2 hours and
36 minutes which is it's a solid League
but honestly I would have been happy if
it was like 4 hours which I know
production-wise never would be allowed
but two hours 30 I'm like okay at least
it's reasonable like I was the old like
I mean I'm kind of a fanboy on them you
know superhero movie so even Justice
League like you can give me a hard time
I just you know I sat back I enjoyed it
like there's moments in there when flash
is running fast and turns Superman turns
his head while it's moving oh oh crap
haha boobs in there what are really cool
is like but it wasn't even two hours I'm
like how do you do Justice League in
less than two hours so let us see this
one's at least a little bit longer
absolutely this is like a geek comic
kind of like Lord of the Rings trilogy
kind of equivalent I look at it
already you know from the comic
standpoints gonna be fun read I'm ready
this this is one of my favorite
storylines of all time and complication
three so trail announced today right on
time with flashpoint a flashpoint anyway
we actually that long not long so we
will see though don't hold your breath
because I don't want anybody passing out
[Music]
tis true what's going on in the world
it's this game that we love what's
happening right now well we finished up
iron banner last week so hopefully you
guys enjoyed that I played a little bit
we got the auto rifle I should have
probably got the pulse as well with all
the patch stuff we had come in last week
but this had sometimes regrets a grand
for one a little bit I figured I'd saved
my iron banner real time for when it
goes 66 here you know he makes
potentially so it may be coming back
quick because we got a heads up the
faction wars are coming right back like
yes not a lot of downtime in here so
literally next week March 20th before
the patch drops we have another faction
rally which I mean it's fine I guess it
gives us something in the interim
because I did my weekly reset this week
it was like pretty tame weekend destiny
you even got a nightfall and some
milestones I'm like in every verse has
some stuff and I'm out like it was it
was a real short there was an alliance
parents tumbleweeds going on in the
tower right now yeah it's it's rough
there's too many things and it's like
between twitch and fort 95 place Oh
shout out to Drake blowing up what night
oh my lord that it is hit the
stratosphere down mmm
yeah it is crazy I mean ninja bacon like
I don't know
solid bunny per month it's like if you
can didn't even keep it for a few months
like dude you're good for a while just
don't blow it all if somebody needs to
sit him down and be like I've been here
I've made some money whoever's done this
manage it well and you'll be alright
like if you can just handle like three
or four months make you know put away a
couple million bucks pay his taxes on
and be good like at his age yeah you're
set for a little while just be smart
with it so yeah hopefully
but there's the practical side of me
coming out yeah something like that take
you know happen people win the lottery
and blow it all it's like so mm-hmm
hopefully not but if action realities
are coming back they're like you know
they're seeing a dead orbit will return
to glory future Oracle is desperate for
its first win trying to get one on the
word shiny gift of wine disable a
tournament but we'll come back to that
later look like they child it they look
like they really rigged this thing you
just do what you did stuff they were
like look you're getting one of the
others one of the others and it would be
really photo people I'd just like now
we're just gonna go with it he wins it's
gonna be Royal Flush all the way through
there's no chance of beating them if
they win that's the only I'm really
curious I'm not gonna play this one but
I'm curious because what does he know
these guys got two snipers right it's um
yeah yeah one one yet Wow so there's a
new weapon rule available so the reward
pool has a shotgun for new monarchy
shotgun for future war cult and what
looks to be about a submachine gun but I
haven't looked it up yet but definitely
in that realm so that's gonna be just in
your reward pool for engrams and stuff
like that so more things to get like
just even like the shape between the two
shotguns even you've got a lot more of a
you know pump-action feel a bigger grip
and then the future war cult of course
it's a little sleeker not the giant
barrels of I mean I was like the art
team which we'll get to can't wait to
see what they're gonna do and some later
but I mean again like they do well no
question so those are not the only
weapons up for grabs whichever effect
should have redeems the most as always
gives their chance at it and we've got
future war cult sniper looking like it's
got a giant silencer on the end here
huge almost like a Darcy look a little
too but yeah don't say that it's not the
same model we will say that about the
asset tea meal we will move on but we
got new monarchy with a grenade launcher
so I'm okay with the look of it not bad
looks kinda cool like you know decent
legit you got the vents on the front big
octagonal you know case they're for
clip whoever that thing doesn't out pull
I mean it's a grenade launcher yeah all
terrible all awful where's architect
audibly in a game so that needs you need
to go ahead like slap just a machine gun
on top of there and have a grenade
launcher on the bottom that you can use
cuz that's the only way I'd probably be
right now that's actually a good idea
actually a great idea like machine guns
have like a thunderlord
in that bad boy you don't say it on top
of it like mo order to grenade pop and
it's like we found a way to fix grenade
launchers slap mono machine gun exactly
they want him back you still get your
all your other stuff in there so
absolutely yeah just fix some things
then right left in here's no I'm just
kidding because I'm not a programmer so
I could never do any of that
but we have ideas we're idea man mmm-hmm
and then we've got dead orbit sniper
rifle that I'm actually gonna take it as
well it's just I don't know they're very
different like the future were called
looks like you know it looks like
basically a pulse rifle with a giant
barrel strapped on the end net orbit one
looks a lot more unique I mean the grip
the longer barrel doesn't look like it
actually has a real gun shape to it it's
it's definitely more rifle shaped agreed
almost a bit extreme on the length of
the barrel but you're walking around
you're like yeah I just have a telephone
moment on my back the look is definitely
that yeah so we'll see I don't know are
you gonna pledge anything what's yours
if you gotta at least jump on and be
like ah I'm gonna pledge at least hope
for a win are you gonna go to tonight
let's just gonna keep it all the way
real with you at this point only reason
why I'm doing a faction rally mean Lord
Cognito if are some more new Monica
shaders that's about it like we've no
whist night bazaar in the Damned no but
then again it may air in your defense it
may be one of them situations where you
know what my I might just maybe pledge
somewhere else just to see
I want to see like the rolls I mean on
these weapons too you know I mean and
we'll see those Tuesday so when I say
weapons I mean Justice nieghbors because
I don't care what the grenade like I can
fire 50 grenades I'm like they're all
gonna miss that's still fine like I just
want to see so if there's like a some
crazy roll on one of these then I might
say to my sorry you know what let me log
you missed me the only week there's been
no new marketing go in and even I'm in
the market somebody's only week they
might let me get if one of those snipers
like I'm a really good roll and then the
meta changes you right ready for one
point one point four yeah Commodus typer
you know with the changes government is
like you might want to pick up the
snipers just to be saying yes they say
exactly - that bad boy in the vault and
you just see how to better plays up yeah
pretty much yeah I don't know I was like
after playing so much of a night fall
recently material amorsolo I did finally
get one no only took me almost all of
last week to do it but I finally popped
mmm working on one this will probably do
a little more today but what I want in a
grenade launcher is what the minotaurs
have for the VEX grenade launchers those
little quick arcing blasts and just it's
a quick blast hit the ground like let me
have that a lot more powerful hits a lot
stronger than ours ours like TT up no
it's oh no it's go it's over there
nevermind so flex so as you guys know I
mean we're sitting you're talking about
faction rallies and we're like yeah it's
kind of there you know you you might get
a gun it's probably just a reskin know
they wanted to address it now again when
did this game come out 2017 yeah early
September it's been six months and now
they're getting to the point where
they're like hey this will be your last
chance to be earning the ornaments for
season two so if you're missing anything
make sure you grab them this will be the
last one until basically season 3 they
want to take a little time they want to
do a little revamp on it we're like okay
what they want to do they're not telling
us what they're going to do but the
goals they're trying to achieve are as
follows pledging to affection should be
a meaningful choice mmm it's a good
start I'm not
for how to implement it rewards should
not be time gated so who do you think if
you just win it it's just something you
can buy it's just like open and then as
you go through the season maybe you add
the second slot there is that sounds
possible yeah it sounds continuous
almost like d1 ish yeah just leave it
there a faction rally should provide a
unique gameplay experience no no we're
kind of talking and not simply be a
reward layer on top of the existing game
now that end of that sentence keeps
throwing me I've read it like four times
I'm like what does that mean what do you
think that means because to me it's
still weird
alright this synopsis is a fact around
should not just be trash but being
series no yes it's like okay when I hear
when I see the sentence should provide a
unique gameplay experience and not
simply be a reward layer so basically
the way I when I see that sentence it it
literally reminds me of when you log in
on reset write what I consider our
reward layer is flashpoint call to arms
you know it basically lists yeah it's
just a milestone list on a login screen
on a director screen so they want to
make it integrated they wanted to be
unique and you know with the next sent I
think that ties into the next sentence
when you get to yeah so the event should
grant additional insight into faction
lore and goals mm-hmm yes I mean for one
wife just you know had an exciting day
so anything with lore is always a good
thing for I mean at me but that's you
have a world that you've built you have
these factions that people have like dug
into weapon descriptions and things like
that to figure a decent amount out of
that they're listened to like set their
next to a person just like we recorded
all like the random lines that come out
of people just to get some idea what's
going on and we're like how do we not
have more by now it's been four years
more that's great and then it should
build upon player interest in lost
sectors and our animal armor ornament
objectives so first off player interest
in lost sectors you're going to need to
go ahead and make lost sectors matter
before we have interest in those lost
sectors yeah
and then armored ornament objectives I
mean like those are kind of cool those
are at least something a grind force if
you have one I don't mind the way they
did that if you have an ornament and
that's what I think more things have I
don't know where I heard I was actually
Guardian radio I'll kind of cover in a
second I was listening to that one but
all of this yeah I mean if they're gonna
make it unique and we've talked about
stuff before I mean have a live running
tally somewhere in the game where you
can you know go in and check with yours
and be like up or even if you just you
go up to the person you can check and be
like that seems we're in third place
right now I'm looking at that brothel
you guys might want to pick it up it's
like even if you just have random things
when you can log in your tower like it
bounces it just checks a thing so
whichever when you talk to you know
who's winning like even if it's
something like that if they're afraid of
doing something live that can still be a
way to be like okay like this is where
we're at so you kind of know no doubt
some but also as you know they're saying
that it should be a meaningful choice
let me ask you and I a monarchy just for
a couple of reasons mostly because it
looks the best in this game a lot of
generally a lot of people are dead orbit
a new one
Absalom do you think you should just get
one account two choice not three mmm
good question I would say it's got a
better some I mean but then again you
know if you got three characters you
know do you want to be locked in account
wise all the way through you know I mean
I think they're you kind of have to give
that flexibility that do you want a head
which is you know per character you can
you can pledge and let's just say you
know again you want to listen you want
to reward players who actually have time
investment in your game a person who has
multiple characters you know I mean has
shown time investment in your game so
you don't want to penalize them so I say
you kind of have to end and like I said
the original game had that feature so I
think they have to kind of stay with
that it's just allowing you to switch
but no we need character so how do you
bacon a meaningful choice though what do
you do what do you think they could do
to you know if you pledged to it make it
more meaningful
then you know just 15,000 glimmer verse
1,000 glimmers link its to our like if
you didn't pick the right faction with
that character you can't buy the weapon
at all like say if you have less than
you just flat-out miss out I'm trying to
make it matter like they weren't I mean
they want the faction were to be like
hey if I'm going for new monarchy this
is the week I may play a little more
than usual just to try and have this
thing win like right they want it to
meet more so yeah that's a good question
I don't know how they actually implement
that I mean again outside any things
that we've talked about which is to me
the issue comes down to you know where
it's like you know what the time gated
stuff and and in the fact that okay I
want to be also I like the grinding for
the ornaments that's dope but I also
want to be grinding for like some type
of recognition we'd said faction like d1
had yeah you know your new monarchy
banners you had that exotic you know the
exotic like the last item you know and
here's the thing like these ornaments
again no disrespect to mark if you want
like they gotta be very they gonna stand
out yeah like they've really got to be
expressive like the same thing like um
but I think I thought they did a great
job a good job with the iron banner ones
right but a lot of the other one I'm
into like you don't say like okay you
making me grind but I want to stand out
for this crime I will you know I mean
the game is like they had again we talk
way too much about d1 but there's a
reason
what about chroma there we go what about
trials rewards whether you have wings on
your backs like ornaments that actually
are like three-dimensional effects like
hey they got you've got to go all out
you you you have to make that person
feel cool you got a black look at that
guy are that was what that was one of
the hooks of d1 d1 what maybe ones are
great for people who listening like why
did a me talk about he wasn't with
well maybe one so great is fashion
mattered it was cool on top of that yeah
it was cool looking it mattered and you
had jealousy in the tower wait this guy
get that you know you're like you're
looking at I remember when I'm falling
saber strike and I saw another warlock
where in that crazy helmet I'm like
where did you get that yeah you know
come to find out that was a strike
specific reward you know I mean it's
that kind of a thing you make it tough
but once one also once it's being tough
you've got a really go ornate expressive
all you got to go over the top with the
ornament in my opinion yeah you know to
make it really stand out but you were
saying that was kind of the thing we
went through when we had we had a rise
of iron and they finally really stole
the raids und won with some of the best
ornaments and looking loot that I've
ever seen yes
those sets that you got from the Kings
fall raid and crota Curtiz in raid none
of those were awesome awesome yes I mean
and Steve as well the deceiver raid also
was those ornaments like how do you end
d1 like and then your ornaments or your
kind of version that you get for doing
the prestige Leviathan raid which it's
gonna you know you're gonna beat your
head against the wall you're like a
different color of shiny gold that's all
it is thank you like I did it was so
disappointing to see the prestige raid
armor yep I'm like this is like that's
not a go like so again you know there
are team is usually good so I think they
really have to nail that I'm curious to
see how the strike specific rewards
gonna go I'm curious to see how they
address that moving forward because you
can't give people generic looking stuff
after they grind it I'm sorry that's not
gonna do it you know know for sure and
it's like if you so it's like between I
mean that's one of those things where
it's like you got to have prestige
matter same thing they want to have
pledging to a faction matter it's like
so say I pledge to a faction
and you did it the first time and say
you pledged to them the second time in a
season you have a chance to get
something maybe the first time didn't go
through and maybe it's just one thing
maybe your second time through you might
get you know a little glow on your head
or I mean and that's so minor I don't
even want to say that they might feel
like yes okay here's another aura but
but instead like if I'm gonna go through
it's like take what I'm about to say and
apply it to factions if they say if
you're gonna do the raid in your normal
raid perks you're gonna go to be like
okay raid armor you get okay you got one
piece okay you got 25% damage bonus on
solar and for your class item so say if
you prestige say that bumps 30% 35% so
it gives you a reason to want to get
that new set of armor anything here just
let me give us a reason and give us
something that effects and how our
character feels and plays by grinding
something more difficult or spending
more time in the game that's what you
guys want us in the game you gotta give
us a reason you're probably gonna be a
broken record between now and who knows
when things come out but that's probably
gonna come up a lot we have to have a
reason to want to play yeah well I mean
the goals are good they're vague and
broad but they're all our things we've
thought about so we'll see how they
implement them I'm not saying you know
Bungie stupid by any stretch there's
some people over there cross the fingers
hoping that they figure out a unique way
to put this in so absolutely and just
for the record you know I want to say
that I thought this paragraph is
positive I really did like I didn't
think they would address it you know I'm
saying because this is stuff we've been
kind of clamoring that fraction rally's
needs to improve it needs to matter it
needs to hold weight and for the most
part these haven't called you know the
bullet points tenants for what they
envision faction rally to be it's pretty
cool like yeah it shouldn't be time here
it should be meaningful meaningful you
know it shouldn't be just that layer you
know it should be an a unique insight so
it's gonna be curious to see how they
implement it how far they go with it but
again new Bungie new transparency a lot
I noticed is a small thinking micelle
you just you know they haven't done
anything it still but it's like it they
listened to all the feedback and every
pretty much you read this paragraph is
like yes this is literally almost
everything I'm thinking now let's see
what comes next
acknowledgement the acknowledgement is
so key you have to acknowledge after
have your ear to the ground
you know what the base wants you at this
point in this stage of the game you have
to do the division you have to do a
rainbow six siege you have to listen to
your community or else that's me right
now just for the record but yeah we just
we all want it to be in its light and
this is one of those it's like
acknowledgement is one implementation is
phase two and that's just as important
you can say all this seems nice and then
if you give us a point oh one percent
increase and all that random stuff that
we've seen before the takes us down the
road again you show me that number I'm
like okay if I'm hitting for like 60 so
yeah I'm gonna do point oh five percent
I'm like I don't know what math you're
doing but I'm pretty sure it doesn't
mean squat
I'm gonna keep my language clean now
we're just gonna roll on down the page
here and see what does high score mean
well apparently for some people that
means cheesing these strikes so pure
media nightfall we had a couple high
scores shout-out to esoteric number one
984 they're on number three so always
good to see him getting any of his
accolades so ah but honestly they said
you know guardians are posting
astronomical numbers because they found
a way to juice the lost sectors they're
looking for a fix in 1.2 which means
you've got until May before that gets
fixed so if you want a realistic
high-schooler just going just challenger
yourselves like unless you want to go
and try and cheese the high score so you
can get it as ridiculously high as
possible because that's what these
people are doing yeah facts yeah I was
like there's I wish there was a point
where and I know there's probably a
balance of somebody who's got like if
we're looking at three hundred eighty
thousand I watched a doe do his video I
think he got like a
thirty know you like 139 129,000 he was
like yeah he's like we got clutch like
literally they finished it was like 1756
to make sure when they killed the boss
they still got points and they're like
they were happy about that and I look
over into see these numbers I'm like
well that just sucks not for I mean for
Daddo because this is just like okay I
had a really good run they looked pretty
smooth and there people are sitting here
doing this I'm going that doesn't
doesn't even make sense so I don't know
if I totally agree with them
acknowledging these to a point like for
them if you had like a couple people go
through do a relatively clean run I mean
a max of two hundred thousand if you see
it's like we're getting double and
triple then you're like all right go
cheese our stuff cuz the way we actually
want you to do it and shoot things
doesn't matter I don't know I mean I
know they're trying to make the best of
a crappy situation because they can't
figure out how to lock them out but I'm
still not sure I like like a broken high
score which is late I think they've got
no choice though I mean they they
laughing at I mean legit pretty much
saying you you know using terminologies
like Ashton amico numbers they know
what's going on I mean you're just doing
it out of O'Malley because I guess they
they have this in place you know in the
system as far as movement when people
post up knife or scores I think this is
the system they were gonna plan to use
now it's just that people are juicing
this like okay we had to revisit this
yeah make a fake will save others have
said hey see who can be the most
efficient running up these scores with
these methods so game on
oh I mean if you want to go for a high
score you're gonna have to get creative
so we all go solo and nightfall two
people go kill stuff in log sectors four
days and then I'll finally pull you into
the bathroom no but you're still gonna
be quick so I mean there's skill
involved in getting something this high
I'll give him that because you can't
just like lollygag and have people go
farm it for an hour and then lose all
your points it doesn't work that way but
yeah there's a balance there so mmm we
get a little bit more about the destiny
to companion app so they're just
continually making some updates there so
it's just you know they have
difficulties that they're working at it
so I'm just giving you guys bits and
bits and pieces of pointers to make
things work they also said now
foul emblem variants each strike offers
a unique emblem that can be earned I
said they've been witnessing some
confusion of like why did that never
seem a variant or whatever so there's
certain strikes and stuff like that so
just you know keep grinding if you
didn't go I get it may just not be high
enough for what they thought the bar was
catchy outside of that a couple of
movies of the week and then we go a
little little tease here in the end of
this one so they said they've been
monitoring the response and gathering
your feedback for all the sandbox and
crucible changes we told you about last
week so before we have them in our hands
we're guessing and speculating they're
listening so I don't know if that's
gonna change anything the patches are
probably been with you know Microsoft
and Sony for a while now but yeah they
did say they wanted to give a little
feedback about in air accuracy so the
sandbox team is going to be letting us
know that in they're going to increase
the fire accuracy and 80s accuracy for
hand cannons they said they're also
going to look at the in air accuracy for
these as well
so basically just interact curacy is one
of those things a lot of people are like
if I want to be skillful and be jumping
in the air why do I have to get
penalized we know I'm a guardian exactly
like if a human being jumps up in the
air and tries to turn and fire gun yeah
you're probably gonna miss but if I'm a
Guardium supposed to be this elite
warrior you know give me benefit the day
out I'm probably gonna hit the shot or
at least have a pretty good chance so I
think that's what they're looking for
yeah absolutely I'm glad that they
addressed it because I you don't believe
it was a triple he had put something out
there in reference to that you know all
screaming about inner ecstasy and then
needing to be fixed and how you know it
was basically in relationship to how it
wasn't d1 so I think they did have a
comment on it and you know they say look
we're looking into it again that this is
important you know a lot a lot of people
definitely you know want to be rewarded
for that for that style of play that was
a big that's a big part of go-fast right
having that going fast heightened
skating doing that you know jumping
around you know that that's part of it
so people want that whole experience you
know they don't want to be punished or
penalize for going in the air and like
you said being a powerful Guardian and
pulling off some you know some really
cool cool moves man zone good to see
them get in front of that
so we'll see what they do with it yeah I
was like there's a there's probably
gonna be a whole lot of patch goats for
us to talk about come two weeks oh yeah
oh so much to talk about a little bit of
playing hopefully before that in a
couple days so we will see but I also
said is speaking of one point one point
four they're going to give us a little
glimpse little Show and Tell for the
nightfall unique rewards that are gonna
be coming next next patch so one point
one point four so you got me hopes and
he thinks any thoughts I'm hoping man
I'm really hoping they don't screw this
one up this one is so important to me so
so important you know unique rewards
it's so important and again it's gotta
be cool it's gotta be over the top it's
got bike into their defense I'm hoping
they nail it because I believe it was a
two flashpoints ago they were kind of
like look well what remember when they
made the announcement that they would
not they pull back oh yeah right and
they did kind of state like hey we want
this to be cool we want to give our
artists they specifically say we want to
give our artists more time yeah so again
I want to see something fly yeah I don't
want to see no you know generic Vanguard
looking gear just another reskin and
this vice pull strap oh I better not see
every skin and it so looks like I broke
off his arm and I'm walking around with
it yeah uniquely yeah spoils of war
unique to that type of situate
absolutely it's gotta be cool man it's
gotta be cool so go through I'm trying
to think of a strikes I just got done
beating my head against the pyramidion
so Brockie on yes a little pulse sniper
rifle
so rifle sniper rifle something in that
department maybe I heard weapons because
honestly I heard that they were gonna be
weapons not armored enjoy somewhat I
wish I both yeah you heard for sure that
it would be just I don't know for sure I
feel like I heard it someone that it was
gonna be weapons and not armed and now I
could be wrong so if you're listening to
be like no you're totally wrong
I thought I heard at one point so I'm
atleast in the in the weapon department
I can speculate what about I mean you
know rocky on the giant you know yeah
yeah cubic Minotaur what would you not
even Minotaur he's kind of his own thing
what would you want exactly remember
when they get the Titan from prisoner
elders had that look like a 747 missed
that over-the-top ornate embellishment
of armor but it's signified what you be
what she did you know mm-hmm
love it like you did it like there's a
point when you go through and you do
damage to him you kind of he's got the
bigger
I call him horns cuz I'm playing too
much monster hundred basically they are
like the giant you know appendages on
the top like and you shoot and you do
enough damage and they break so it'd be
kind of cool if you got it in that mid
phase before his head pops off but once
those horns are broken so it's not like
off your screen but it's kind of that
point where it's like they're kind of
broken but you still get the semblance
of the head and I looked like a vex guy
now I've got a vex thing on my head so -
he's like this doesn't look big enough
her head can you fit your head in here
it doesn't you know I'm talking about
like there's like so I was like but if
you put that on totally changes the face
for a little while do it like give me a
goofy looking head for a little while
it's fine absolutely I mean that's
that's the level I want with those
though be it armored be it weapons like
if it's a weapon
I want literally his arm just give me
his arm strap it let me hold it that's
good I'm with it now with it all about
that spoils of war pieces and him go
ahead no go ahead no I mean just
completely agreement with you yeah so
we'll figure out if Cosmo is actually
the one controlling the strings on the
faction around this because you say he's
pledging the future war cult see if they
can get him a win so if he picks them
and they win I just blame Cosmo nothing
else
you know only snipers I do think new
monarchy has a tough road this coming
week
her name sure hopefully puts you in not
the backseat but I'd say basically puts
you in the trunk yeah you don't have a
shot
yeah they shouldn't they shouldn't wait
you know funny though if they still win
it is just like they're just gonna you
know at that point I'm gonna leave my
screen clean right now if on your end
you want to see if this little roadmap
update is up I doubt it but if you want
to check real quick they said they're
planning to update the roadmap tomorrow
as we're recording this is today now
it's probably a little early because
they're west coast and this is ill 7:39
in the morning for them absolutely so I
doubt it's up but sometime middle middle
of the day this afternoon there will be
a road map update so I'm sure we will
talk about that next week
mm-hm probably in the slob next week so
we'll see what's coming it's probably
just like hey this is where we're at
this is what we expect to get in here if
anything got pushed back to May and then
they need to start adding a new column
saying hey this is the stuff that might
be in fall with taking king 2.0 or
whatever so they need to start adding
that next column in there cuz they've
they believe it they only showed that
stuff like I think one time when they
mention all the stuff they're looking at
the like this is the stuff we're looking
at for the fall they haven't mentioned
that stuff again yeah good point they
haven't won anything with weapons slot
allocation and yes all those like those
bigger chunks with people like okay you
have my interest piqued its big what is
is anything happening here and we
haven't heard anything about it so yeah
absolutely it would be very interested
to see what what edom is and added moved
in or move back so let's see what
happens you know May is a big one you
know that that's that's gonna be in
kinshasa season 3 is gonna be in
conjunction with the DLC so they've got
a lot to prove there and I'm gonna be at
a pack this year so um I'm curious I'm
very confident they're gonna have a
presence there cuz I think they've got
up Ramon you know in fact is April
they've got to kind of get the promotion
training it would be fitting because
they don't have they don't have a patch
anything going on so that's like seems
like you know ramp up your
Marketing for whatever's coming in time
in April before May so yes you need a
marketing barrage let's be honest
because they're not even there's no
mindshare right now there's not no one's
even these updates that sound amazing
these go fast updates the mind shares
just not they're the people to even be
you know talking about nesting right now
so I think they gearing up probably for
that and you Anna brakes panshin with
the warm ons it's got to be cool man
yeah I mean that needs to almost feel it
needs to be bigger than it should be
that's yes yes like what we expect for
an expansion what we're used to what we
even want it almost needs to be a little
bit bigger just to give your player base
a reason because if it's not that big if
it's tier you know four or five mission
thing in morale and you've got like one
landing zone so say it's like Mars with
like five events and you've got one big
a circle for the language so good so
good put it yeah if it said none if it's
just like five missions on a new planet
and then what's the big thing you have a
prison of elders thing like if they just
do that people are gonna lose their mind
and I don't know like I don't know if
you could get them back so it needs to
be better than it even probably should
be it's one of those like so we'll see
Absalom
but shout out so unknown player so no so
he had a video talking about some
concept art that got out there for
destiny to con scenes that got cut from
the game so we'll see on screen we've
got the images they took from kind of
whatever was out there basically and
again these are concept art but Cognito
brought it to my attention again it's
just the idea of what else could have
been so as you were mentioned before we
got started it destiny one had a
somewhat darker feel instance I mean you
see taking King and you watch that
cutscene you like okay you just wiped
out some people you see crota and you
were talking about the torture that with
like six went down one came out
like what happened to the other five
that's a bit ominous like there's some
stuff going on in there and I mean you
talk about the fight at the wall with
Siva and like the amount of people that
gave their lives the opening cutscene
with them all died Lords sacrificing
themselves behind like behind them all
like there's I mean they went a lot
darker as opposed to I mean the feel of
destiny - especially when you fall off
of calluses ship music the tone the
darkness you're limping like that was
cool
like you put that with like the gravity
of some of the stuff like Indy one story
and I was like I think you could that's
where they like go darker like that's
when things mean more yes we would
things have wait so like you want a
story some of them that's unfortunately
what it's like some people are like not
always keen on dramas you know you want
to watch TV do you want that separation
but when you play a game like The Last
of Us and you either go through that
first ten minutes which is like a movie
it just rips your heart out or you
finish it up and your minds going what
the hell just dance like yeah you have
those moments and it's like if you want
a game to be impactful mm-hmm
you need to give those moments more
weight absolutely and I think I'm gonna
say some controversial you hunt is gonna
be mad
I love Kate we all look who doesn't love
Kate I'm the problem
yeah the problem I felt would be too is
they knew they had something special
with Kade and the focus not that the
whole story was about Kate it wasn't but
if you look at the promotion of destiny
- it was really about Kate it was it was
at the bar that was the first teaser
ever second Kate it's me
USA so again if you're gonna go that
route it's funny it you know it's it's
cool you know but it's like again the
tone think about that compared to when
we got to taking king trailer right
thinking teaser and stuff like that like
Oryx is common now again you did feel
gall I'm not gonna say you didn't feel
gone what's that it was common yeah it
is presence but like I said as you I
don't know I just I feel like
the overall vibe of d2 is in a shout to
unknown player for his video and
comments I agree because I feel like
it's just kind of light-hearted funny
hahaha you know I don't take it in and
I'm gonna say something else really
controversial now you got me going on
here three bucks all the time yeah
alright
I'm gonna say something I thought I'd
never say maybe part of it also is due
to Nolan back and the fact that your
character doesn't speak right anymore
yeah I was like keep going but I gotta
let you count Matt they're almost done
with the tangent these character doesn't
speak anymore
Nolan bar is doing all the talking this
time yes he is funny but a lot of the
time it's jokey jokey stuff almost say
like this really there's no seriousness
for a lot of time that's why I mean I
actually like sukira a little bit you
know I'm saying was ear King mm-hmm
that's pretty much what I got on it is
just like they've made a conscious
decision marketing-wise storyline wise
that we're not gonna make this series to
me the most serious thing that I felt in
the entire destiny to probably cinematic
story wise was the end you know spoiler
alert if you can be to literally the you
know prologue well you don't want to
crap a log or do you want to call it
after goal is defeated yep the travelers
light goes out yeah you know I'm saying
what it at letting we will scroll down
into the to the art you'll see what I'm
talking about more than triangle shades
which we are assuming or the darkness
that's the threes gonna be lit when that
comes you know I mean right so it's like
that was the only moment where I felt
like you know but I feel in fear like I
don't know just just just just different
maybe the easiness of the games just so
many things now I'm alive done I'm done
rambling it's all legit and it's one of
those things and you can have said just
the humor to a point mmm
Kate before I think was liked so much
because he was those a little bit
uplifting points yes he was the moment
and one of my favorite lines in all of
d1 from the entire game is get your rock
off my mat for his personality but still
in that it's the one I remember but it's
still in that situation you also have
Aris like explaining the gravity of
what's going on and that gives it more
weight to because it's like he has a
little blip and yeah I remember that one
cuz it cracks me up but in turn you get
the weight of Eris's voice like the
feeling even when she's been through you
see like the black coming out from under
her eye mask like you are looking at
those moments and going okay this is
something I don't really want to mess
with and we have a little levity in a
joke in there because that's Kate and
that's like perfect in doses yeah and
I'm not saying like take Kate out but as
you said if you make the focus on
something humorous that's what the whole
thing becomes exactly as a weird weird
metaphor here and got a stick with me
but you'll probably kind of understand
why go for it
Marvel vs. DC movie
perfect I think Marvel is oh it is
always jokey which unfortunately in turn
the same thing we're talking about take
some of the gravity away that's why
Marvel has an issue with the villains
yes
now Civil War was internal struggle that
was different so you did the the villain
was literally just like moving pawns on
a chessboard but the main focus is the
internal struggle different but I got to
come for you to look black and then
Black Panther took it to a level it
should have been yes black panther
crushed it because you have a villain
that has understandable and empathetic
motivations
and you can feel for him and you also
have the main protagonist get the crap
kicked out of him well I mean if it's a
movie obviously he's coming back so I
mean you know he's coming back but you
have those moments too where it's like
okay like this is it's real and it has
weight to it before you're kind of going
okay but you turn over to DC and this is
where you kind of have to balance it to
DC almost goes too far in the dark yes
sometimes like they go for it like
Justice League was kind of a fun little
balance and they had a little bit more
fun with it
Wonder Woman was really good but they go
definitely more towards the darker more
serious side and sometimes I appreciate
that because almost everything like
ant-man is funny but there's a point
where it's like it's almost just a pure
comedy and they're special effects in
there I still enjoy the movies for sure
don't get me wrong
absolutely but in turn like you have
something like flashpoint the movie like
if they do a real flashpoint movie and
the way that time can like that in the
TV show I'll give him props cuz he went
through you know he wanted to change
time at the end of the season he comes
back and it's like you just messed with
your entire world because you because
you wanted one thing it has consequences
and that's the point of like that's the
metaphor you have you can't go too far
to the Marvel humor side and get rid of
the gravity of a situation if you know
what happens absolutely completely agree
completely so bringing it back to full
circle juice on screen here that will
show you guys apparently there was an
idea for a much darker destiny - yeah so
we're gonna stroll down the first one
here it looks weird I've been looking at
this image long enough it's like you've
been staring at the clouds I literally
see a face here you have what looks like
some cloud around it probably the
traveler in some black I can't even tell
exactly what this is it's weird but down
here is pretty cool yeah you got a
couple hands I don't know if it's like
either dematerializing or just covered
an ash a demo Ark like dream imagery
with us it looks like
kind of a foggy explosion in the
background or something to keep in mind
it's constantly a park from these
artists I believe what school like
travelers dream or something like that
is cinematic and you'll see some pieces
that kind of came back in that were part
of what we're in the game so you can
guess is kind of related so can you
focus a little more on the hand you can
tell there's the particles around it
it's like ash it's dark that's me
so the end of d2 you see that the
triangle ships darkness is the thing
piece of concept art they actually put
it in a rendered video so they spent so
a little bit of time on it so you have
an image where it's sitting next to the
traveler like and look at the scale
that's gonna start to make earth look
small depending on the size of that ship
I mean this mmm look like it's calm
something's common and then I like the
little minions like they look like a
swarm so so I love that concept part
yeah I thought for a second when I was
watching the video that all the little
ones made up the big one it was actually
like nanites building almost like a
collective hive hive mind and then they
also dispersed I got to it's what you
said that I was thinking the same thing
I was like I kept staring at the ship
I'm like is it it doesn't look like they
do but maybe I don't know so and that
little lips when you can see like some
slight trees below you got to travel and
give this big-ass triangle ship so yeah
it's a bit rough these ever just start
to get a little darker it looks like I
mean this looks like basically just a
mass grave covered in ash and soot and
whatever I mean this is but it's like
this is dog this is end of the world
kind of stuff you know I mean I like
this this is what I'm talking about you
you gret you bring wait you bring like
oh man this is our reality if we don't
defeat this thing like loving it yeah so
I mean that one there it's just like
yeah the kijima would be proud of this
and yeah it's could you awareness Reyes
I like it down but I mean you've got
what looks like either a human face
small child it doesn't look big like the
but it's like covered in oil some black
liquid mm-hmm yeah so I mean again here
same thing you've got it bird but it
looks like it's made of I mean
player known was saying it's like the
black wiring and stuff like that
it's not made of feathers it's not a
real bird anymore something's up like
it's yeah and if that's like if that's
what happens if the darkness takes over
it's like yes to me all this is Dec
results of the darkness like the birds
all tarred up human before bathed in
this thing like they're transforming
their matter I can go on and on like the
web first will shout out to the art team
I mean this was scrapped
so that just let you know yes they like
did it oh man like this is really really
powerful imagery I was really impressed
when I sort of shot in a non-playable
bring this to our attention like really
cool stuff so you got a ghost now they
met I mean we we know Siva we have that
throwback for a second but it doesn't
look truly see the like it's still I
think there's I don't know what the red
color gives in the background if you
black and white at this image it would
still have the same feel as the bird
above with the wiring of the taking over
like the darkness has taken over a ghost
here like mm-hmm
this could be the aftermath of that same
picture I can't tell can't tell yeah but
I mean that's rough it's a problem it's
a problem dude is literally like melting
on the side of his face his eyes are
glowing like I don't think he's coming
back
boy that that's a simulation right you
being taken out like you're part of the
board no yeah you're controlled now
that's it they got you and then here
this is where it's like there were some
of this was in like kind of the dream
and some of them kind of cinema videos
in the opening of D to see if like the
underwater the triangle ships gonna
basically taken over mm-hmm your picture
the Leviathan now this concept art yes
even shows like the planet dying a
little
or I know the concepts are showed a
little bit but you see actually the
literally the vacuum of feeling of like
ripping the pieces of planet inside the
Leviathan like you get a feel of what
it's doing
I completely agree because if this was
necessary this I don't know what it is
it looks like obviously some Lance spear
looking thing you can't yeah I can't put
my finger I don't know what that is at
all but something electrified but
there's not much behind it and then
finally you've got this yeah man oh this
kind of comes back into I think just
some of the probably the cinematic work
that was there and this kind of wraps
probably back to coming out of the drain
maybe or something but just the level of
these images it's the main viewer right
here in the middle you got this one with
the guy yeah it up just completely
assimilated or being completely
destroyed one of the new and then you
know the ghost and the burbles - yeah
that is powerful man but it's I mean you
take something I mean it's been a minute
since I played the halo story but Bungie
has done a story with you know with
Cortana and all of the things and the
rings and just the whole weight all the
way through that of you know the need
and they actually made it feel a little
more they've always said hey the
darkness is coming and then we end up
fighting the Fallen or the valley and
it's like like they open d1 with the
vagaries of you know the darkness and
the traveler and the light and stuff
like that and then we're gonna go fight
these random alien factions it's like so
what about the thing you talked about in
the very beginning yeah you know mention
that no it's gonna be six years later
like come on yeah I mean but you know
what I I'm gonna give them a pass only
for the simple fact that you first of
all you're correct well I'm not even
gonna try to minimize would you what
you're saying is Craig's like we have
not heard from you know the issue thing
we played d1 what we started out for
right everything has been sidetracked to
these other things I think this is just
a nature of MMO I think they know that's
the end game and this is where that
10-year plan comes in because they just
can't give it to us right they can't get
otherwise story be over there's no more
you know a story narrative reason to
continue so now you have to throw these
out a little side plots and stuff around
here in a minute I call this one that
one and then it eventually gets to you
like think of it like um Game of Thrones
in a way at the end of the day we knew
from you know from Season one we knew
the White Walkers were coming right yeah
but it's just like they trying to
establish all these other things and and
then you know give you a little bit of
hint here and there about that but I
think ultimately that's what it is that
you know the darkness is there White
Walkers
yeah d4 or do whatever it is that the
story actually ends you know same with
that character yeah it's like it's a lot
of buildup but you're gonna keep people
around long enough to get to the Builder
mean I don't know so anything else going
on with you right now so I know as
you're saying you're like not really
even playing the pelo faction or any
what else you've been even playing what
is what is stealing your attention from
this game that we it's been tough it's
been tough because um I gotta be bullion
this is like this is the first time I'm
just like damn there's no motivation you
know for me to go on you know and it's
like um you know obviously one point one
point four we know that I'm definitely
not for that so you know during the
meantime it's just been backlog it's
been backlog that's been told before
XCOM - I've told you these numerous
times I've been playing war the chosen
like crazy that's one of my backlogged
games I got a 4k update I've been
hitting that you know obviously c-beams
drops you know I had Kingdom Come two
lemons you know I'm not a general sway
just got my it's just been backlog after
backlog at the backlog so I mean that's
pretty much like my new routine since
destiny is now part of my life
consistently right you know it's gonna
feel good to want to turn it back on and
you know I just really hope they you
know they got it to get it together you
know I'm dying to see how that fast
update looks
and on but yeah that's pretty much what
I've been doing in the interim you know
it's like me and you had this discussion
offline which is like we did this whole
analogy with destiny to him was gone
hunt to me is just like you know they
got into a car accident got into a car
accident he's all life support improving
I mean it's kind of right it's one life
support right now no one's talking about
this the only we only people mothers
need us so it's like but with that loyal
friend right exact you know everyone's
abandoned all the major streamers so
we're loyal when we know that the joint
happiness this friend gave us so we come
by that hospital you got the flowers you
got the candy you got your card you
checking that you speaking to the doctor
to see what the prognosis is you're like
okay next week he should have full range
of motion in his feet left to go fast
update right now let's just call a spade
a spade that's where we at and we're
just hoping somehow because they've done
it before
we can't say d1 was another car accident
I mean there were different issues with
that true true you know I remember those
stretches before on taking King you know
I mean I remember I remember the drought
I remember that it was rough it was
really bad okay then you had the
division out remember it was bad man for
destiny and then you know they somehow I
was able to pull it out and take it and
they've got a comfort for so we'll
rabbit out of a hat on this one though
absolutely man you use there's no doubt
about it like we got a call it what it
is so interest yeah I was like in may is
gonna be the hopefully some stuff gets
in there it gives a little dabble of
content but it's really whatever is
after me is the one that will probably
like make or break the future of either
D to tell
they're taking a break in reboot or some
of this franchise just overall Igraine
teacher I agree but I will say this I'm
not minimizing the importance of I
didn't make it still important I think
me because here's the thing the quality
of life stuff if destiny is playing
better right and feeling better after
one point one point four and then you
got a nice little decent content drop
with this warm on TLC no nickname so
many leaks now so hard to keep up gods
of Mars yeah so a newly right so I'm
like okay if the game plays better and
the content is actually good not Osiris
like that's gonna be the new term your
DLC is Osiris life forgotten in time
[Laughter]
exactly
oh the infinite circle of nothing well
that's your friend that said something
on the nightstand in the hospital left
again just like peace I'm like dude see
they didn't even do that real file with
his visit to the patient work yes his
look card get well it was out so um yeah
like I think it's just one of the things
we it has potential to Jim you gotta
generate a little buzz you gotta have
that you know that cinematic team put
out that nice trailer you know show some
cool stuff get people excited they have
to get people excited I think they can't
wait as long as that big updated they're
hoping because just too much things
right now captivating people's my I mean
you're playing monster hunter daily
you're going in oh yeah I mean I have
you know I'm not creeping up through the
hours I have in destiny to I've just put
some more time in it but I've got more
time in this game than probably any
other in know quite a while in Monster
Hunter and it's been because it has a
reason for me to keep going even if it's
just
hey it's literally right now sometimes
I'll just jump on and go wail on stuff
to help my brother because he's at a
lower level not quite at the same you
know and I'll go jump in and I feel
powerful so okay I got a question for
you what's up so we'll kind of ended on
this one is kind of a decent way to
route you know down so d2 is struggling
mm-hmm if you had to put your finger and
make a top three over a list you an
example of one for me and that's kind of
basically what I said I want to have a
chance at points to feel powerful amen
amen I want to do a 270 nightfall being
335 and not fear from my life quite in
the same way I want to go into a patrol
and be able to just walk all over half
of that stuff but if I walk into like a
high level patrol and I'll be a little
work like yes so when I go into low rank
in in Monster Hunter and I go work go
hit the first guy he probably takes me
like 20 seconds right now as I move to
my first fight was like going between
zones and like a 20 minute fight I can
kill him about 20 seconds like maybe
maybe that's fast but it's like it's
probably about a minute on low rank and
you don't I have not had that feeling in
d2 ever yeah it is fine so normalized to
wherever you are it also said Amen
that's my one give me one for you yeah I
think you take a break so you can it's
like I'm going for the bigger broader
stuff that was really good man um I
think anything in the pew pew Department
um sandbox I feel just come I actually
confident that they're gonna get Sam out
right I'm confident I like what I'm
hearing I like the verbage from me right
now
I think shout out to document the weapon
slot thingy they I think they have no
choice because
the consensus is people hate the clutter
that's at heavy at heavy weapon at
powwows lot so how do you beat a rocket
launcher you can run with it's like if
you can't beat them you got to work with
them you can't take you're not gonna
beat a rocket launcher right so at this
point maybe you have that fourth slot
specialty weapon I don't know how we got
primary energy have power that's what
they call it now right yeah yeah I say
heavy in my videos the one doing the
dirt person is um yeah man I think I
think they have to do the bold you're at
the point your own life's well you have
to do the book you have to jumpstart the
patient right yeah what do you have to
lose right no one's playing it right now
all right so at the end of the days like
you have to jumpstart the patient you
have to do radical things like we heard
Wow trials gotten already oh yeah okay
right every week we hear like one or two
low mini radical things like really okay
I like that you know I'm saying so
you've got to do a series of that and
you've in the biggest one is the double
down you have to you have to back away
from that whole that old mindset of you
know where we got our boots dug in the
ground and this is what the weapon
system is no I likes it yeah I mean hey
they already stepped back on crucible
right stand I got rubble I got 600 66
let's keep it real right remember before
or before is this experience and that's
what that's what we have to say it this
time nobody liked it you know that so
you you've got pretty much they have to
acquiesce let me ask you a question
sweet breath let's go what if at the end
of the god of Mars or whatever is
trailers like special weapon slot and
they just drop it there
boom you've got to do it you like I mean
if that's the world about it you have to
there's no more
I'm completely on board with dr.
Newton's point because I first me and
you what kind of mindset you know right
September taken King DLC I'm looking at
not to get long-winded again we talked
about this last one I'm looking at that
release calendar y'all October Red Dead
October Call of Duty bro
you you even if you drop this it to me
you may only get a couple of weeks yeah
battlefield 2 so you can play for a
couple of weeks then you're gonna set it
down again exactly if you put it if you
change your development update rome
announce very interesting I hope we get
them I'm retweet I'm actually refreshing
like Twitter every minute you know and
it's just like if they're like you know
stay tuned for this member they saying
he's gonna there's an update to the
development roadmap maybe you gotta push
that thing that you thought you was
gonna put in September into the make out
a wooden it's that dire now me maybe we
wait on well I've got one on things
maybe we I don't know minds or something
maybe we will on
yes a big one much more is a bigger but
maybe we may wait on one of the
deliverables that was promised and bring
this one up you that's what I got man
that's that's my one take some more
exotic duplicates if I have to even
though I got two more the other day oh
man like the way I like ball space I've
like basically accepted it sucks so I
mean I'm with best and on that one
twelve hundred and eighty two or I crack
up every time there was no one of those
mind is like lately the duplicates have
been worse yeah it's been like I got two
more the same I don't even know what it
was piece of armor usually I got two
more the same thing I'm like are you
friggin kidding me mm-hmm
like that's been so predominant for me I
mean and it's not a major gripe so
mmm-hmm that would be too so that way so
let me let me throw this out for the
last piece for three of them or wrap it
up gopher oh yeah for number two I mean
they got to go big for that weapon [ __ ]
and I think that would change
so much and yield the weapons your use
you have an entire power slot and you
have a vault full of stuff I don't even
mess with and talk about feeling
powerful again having you snipe or
having a prayer if you start to feel
fine you feel powerful you so versatile
you know a feel power you don't want to
be able to go write some stuff yes have
the proper weapon stuff I want to be
able to use all my weapons and not feel
like I'm sacrificing everything just to
have a normal load out my number three
no this is my bigger one for taking King
because this is a big rework mods is a
step in the right direction
mm-hmm to just dive headfirst more into
a feel of board of an RPG mmm
gotta get stats meaning a little more
like builds and and pulled more from
division type stuff Armand and
discipline with like a little bit more
health there's a little bit more speed
mobility but I still don't think it's
gonna be much mm-hmm like those level I
want I want and that maybe even like a
d3 where you kind of get more of a
system like that in there but that's the
stuff the hardcore people want
there's no max right now and I mean your
min max even if they do mods 2.0 what
when I get my free mods I mean there's
give me a reason to wear different sets
yeah absolutely
you know they I think mine my counter
today I'm not counter with my equivalent
and shout out to my boy addict you know
I got it at this point yeah I have to
think about the people who are not me
and I'm saying you know who have left
and why they have left and destiny to me
the strength of destiny what may destiny
great shout out to all people listening
we t1 vets we going back memory lane
again but what may destiny one great is
gonna play the game
you beat it okay what else is do do you
do then you find out about that magical
thing called the rate and yeah six of
your buddies and it was the hardest
content you got do it without whatever
here's what I want
you being at the people we know that the
incentives are not where they should be
for the rate right they're trying to
improve that they're doing little things
okay cool
what they also have to do is which they
had in place and I saw this song ready I
forgot who the Reddit user was I was
like a man when I saw his post wrath of
the machine not saying it was the best
rate it's one of my top raised oh um had
it perfect in terms of reward and
incentive to run it again and again
you had the grey chests remember you had
deceiver key fragments so that even if
you got all the rewards you ran it once
but you want to help your butt out the
next week right I mean the same week you
get to see the key fragments and you get
enough of them per segment you can still
get a set a reward remember right the
other thing that the racket machine had
was the UM the different weapons per
difficulty yummy absolutely then it had
the outbreak prime quest they need lots
of those where is that you know I'm
saying so it's like again your strength
Bunji your strength is the rate no game
MMO in my opinion that is what makes one
of the things that really makes destiny
great and I'm gonna really come for
division like division I'm - I'm getting
exciting we talked about that last those
incursions that's not it bro like you've
got to do something like there's nothing
that beats the six-man mechanic of a
destiny raid nothing and my pin the
castle space shout out to you PC guys no
that's it but that's the idea they feel
that yeah you go talking to us console
peasants here I know it watches has
graduated both for a while understand
little cockney those acaso guy when I
got a wreck it was the most exhilarating
feel there's no game that's replicating
that let's keep it round that's the
strength to play To Your Strengths get
people to play that damn raid all the
time you had the formula a d1 mimic that
rise of iron raid formula there was no
reason to take that out no no reason you
had the system you I think
rosin rather the machine was one of the
most rewarding raids then you had you
forgetting the other thing remember on
the the prestige set and then he had the
chromers with the ugly one of Miss not
maybe you didn't like the way that the
raid set look per se but you can't say
that it wasn't wrong
yes it was one of us weren't unique that
it had member I had to see the coming
out you know particles floating up say
what you want about maybe you didn't
like to set itself but you can't say
that the actual rewards and the actual
ornaments that they did and then think
about every little armor piece like one
made you on get on what you call it
every time you kill fallen number it was
giving you on more heavy member time
arms it was a great offer amazing in
that yeah and then your whole deceiver
charge like give you percentage blast
against this deceive it like dude rate
and be like hey boots so if you're gonna
be the one holding the orb you run
faster or you've got an extra jump in
there cover yourself like go to you what
he's in the chair listen to this ramble
we are definitely off train right email
and this is the same idea so give things
more meaning in a different way think
about your ghost it's no one but okay
why do I have six ghosts first and they
all have the same voice and then have
your ghost have like 16 unlockable
things
and get different skins but say like hey
when you get you know a thousand kills
in European dead zone you can give your
ghost like a little bit of like foliage
on it or something like that and if you
go my Oh have your one ghost so I'm not
trying to manage like 16 ghost story
what if you kill thousand people or you
find 50 chests on Eid easy yeah didn't
select of that is your location to turn
on have one that has like five or six
different things on it and that's your
ghost but make it something that you can
unlock some like those type of things I
heard that knows like absolutely and
everybody then a Guardian ready to
agreed they're like a hundred percent
agree like there's why not why not like
it gives her go it makes your ghost mean
a little more cuz it is your ghost you
can have them look a little different
and maybe it goes back to the old just
you know metal ghost and then you can
give him some skins or like foliage or
like a little bit of you know whatever
what is no your ghost it's you that's
gonna be your voice in the game you
can't be switching in and out all the
time I'm gonna use this one now don't
leave this other one in my fault
transfer his voice it they're thinking
about I'm like just the lore of the
story that I love I just think they
won't do it though I love it but ghosts
don't mean anything anyway they don't
make you minimal perks even if you get
some of those exotic ones for ya
occasionally one little blip turn in at
manche the BF telemetry in a minute make
your main ghost make it one make it on
the bottom page move your fourth weapon
slot right up there where the ghost is
that you can boom now you got that like
I said you got the community those are
the once at this point it's it's all out
and back to our main point which is you
know dinky wait I think may is important
man I think may they have a surprise
with deliverables that we didn't think
we're going to happen I think that
that's a good way to phrase it
they got to give us something we didn't
expect even if it's not all we're hoping
for something to be like
okay like this is this is salad look
let's get out there and see like hmm can
it just be one animation of like your
ghost like sliding down to the bottom
page and the new box appearing in there
with an option sniper rifle icon go
that's and that's the fade out they walk
and they drop the mic and they're like
peace we'll see you in a month all you
gotta do it for four months and they can
totally implement a complete reppin
weapon or rework in four months band-aid
it may alright maybe you don't have you
maybe the force lighting ready right so
maybe you just say as of May guess
what's in the energy slot baby those all
can work very right you know I'm saying
look look at your look what's back
thousand-yard stare baby energy slot
holler I'm telling you you ain't got
enough time to do the full Beaufort slot
throw it back like d1 the fans will flip
out what if you get your shotgun Stamper
in Connecticut let's do it
that's alright I think we rambled a lot
here sure does like I mean faction
leaders they're trying to they they've
listened they know people want things to
mean more and I think that's the big
thing we want things to mean more we
want a reason play we want a feel we
want to feel like Guardian said we want
to have a reason to get in there and
feel like a guardian nice what's up
wrapped it up in a nice little tube so
title so haha amen brother preach it to
the choir okay well you wrap this thing
up if you guys have stayed stuck with us
through this one or watch the full video
or listen to however you listen to it
yeah thanks for sticking with us for
Elif of that tangent I think we're
getting back on the train we'll pull it
into the final station metaphors aside
as Jews was always good talking to my
brethren he want is that real destiny
tough and the flashpoint always
transforming the long
but it's great it's gonna be good Sunday
we got you know the Lord's will return
talking that gaming talk trying to lock
down and guess or I will post that to
the ILP Twitter as soon as that is
finalized but we got some good gaming
stuff to discuss Microsoft's plans a lot
of stuff going on in Tendo firmware
updates and you know yeah oh yeah all
tight you can add it your friends
through Twitter now like it's going down
so you have a big show make sure you
tune in the world Nintendo you catch all
that good stuff at the at the roundtable
it's gonna be the Lord's Day Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern that will be on the inner
circle Network channel so please tune in
please support then again you know where
I'm at locally to at Twitter and Xbox
Live and cogno 360 yes and give me a
shout and if you're on Twitter your name
on PSN is Cognito 360 you wouldn't let
me change PlayStation how much of an
Xbox guy you are your playstation name
is three zero I was on ps3 for baseball
and Tekken that interests me Last of Us
came at the end more games on that they
took like Xbox Live that was amazing and
they broke it with exactly so that's
what it was that was my little troll
name I guess I was me you know I
literally said I was like it's my my
baseball PS Vita cuz I used to do remote
play and I forgot what the other was
attacking yeah I want a couple of skis I
always loved the PlayStation controller
for fighters really fold it was superb
for that so that was my thing so where
can the doctor will find you ya know
always I've ever recording these
watching me bash my head against the
nightfall wall so low so that solo go up
yeah I was working on another one the
other night too and I'm sitting there I
was
working through this week it's a garden
world to your face and the big vex mind
at the indy rotates are on the platform
working it nice and slow knock stuff
down then all of a sudden BAM pushed on
platform minutes later doing this got
him down and then it's it's the way the
last couple of bosses have been it's
like you just have to smoke the boss
when he gets down to the low phase
otherwise he's basically impossible to
kill like if you get him down to the
face and you don't dump all your damage
at that point you're done so it's kind
of going through figure and all the
little bit out and say oh you guys gonna
watch me struggle live on twitch.tv
slash e bonus twitter.com slash e bonus
you know updates usually retweeting news
that we see out there new in our nice
little shoutouts for flashpoint and iron
Lords podcast and right here on YouTube
where you guys may have come across this
as well so if you guys haven't hit the
subscribe button on either Channel
please yes that you guys do that support
the channel it helps drop those likes
those comments those shares those really
helped us a lot just spread the word as
much as you can we enjoy all the support
and again it's like one of those random
kind of crazy things I never thought I'd
even have the subscribers I do I know
I'm not the biggest but I was like it's
like I think you guys for the support
and then I go look at my video views and
it's like weird you guys watch me from
40 50 countries around the world and I'm
going how does that even happen any room
like on my computer with my PlayStation
like not the best editing skills and I'm
like I got that so trust me you guys
thank you guys for everything I mean and
that goes for I think both of us for
sure it's just any and all the support
we get we thank you guys for pretty much
every minute of your day that you get
watches region anytime resource and
absolutely it's one of those so yeah
check us all out I am Lourdes big shout
out to them right here on e bonta's my
channel twitch live all that good stuff
so check us both out we'll keep coming
back a couple weeks is gonna be
interesting
we'll have a big flash point with
between patch notes from the 27th the
flob on the 30th and oh it's going to be
big that's gonna be a long point a 1 is
gonna be a long time yeah to talk about
couple weeks will be a long once if you
gotta save it up and you're like hold on
I can't listen you guys that much you
know hold off hang out to save us up for
a couple weeks
well thank you guys so good afternoon
for me it's still good morning or good
evening where have you guys are at
around the entire world thank you guys
for tuning in have a good one peace